you described yourself as a liberal area
and I think a liberal doesn't think that
a society controls women or men well
let's say regulates I'm a psychologist
as well
a woman what is this creature how do we
know when we met one
I'm sure that you've met women in your
life that that that acted towards you in
a bullying and detestable manner it's
very difficult for women to cope with
that because they don't have any real
recourse and female bullying can be
unbelievably vicious and usually it
takes the place of takes the shape of
reputation destruction innuendo and
gossip it's well documented it's very
difficult to defend but you know men do
it too but men no but
in any of you or not sorry yes when yes
disproportionately women that's what the
data indicate I mean if there's the data
on innuendo and gossip well it's among
anti-social Behavior among adolescents
it's a well-documented field